cgi fabrique et distribue des vêtements
de sécurité et réutilisables pour le
milieu hospitalier
l'entreprise a non seulement vendu 300
militaires depuis le début de la crise
mais elle a aussi vidé toutes ses
réserves cette stock là étaient toutes
distribuées dans les premiers trois
jours après que le gouvernement et les
astuces institutions de soins de santé
ont réalisé qu'ils vont voir un problème
voire manque aujourd'hui leurs délais de
livraison au doublé est le principal
fournisseur la chine n'est pas fiable
si il y à de nouveaux corps en chaîne
c'est sûr qu'ils vont changer un peu la
priorité vont peut-être très de garder
les produits pourraient même la solution
une éventuelle pénurie fabriquer tout ce
qu'on a besoin ici même au québec fait
le spect par exemple produit des tissus
techniques pour des clients
internationaux
on peut tout faire celui ci sachent
odieux du fils du tissage du tricotage
de la confection c'est les mêmes
équipements de production
il faut juste plutôt que de faire des
uniformes de pont peace not afin d une
forme de protection pour tous ceux qui
sont en train de ses champs de bataille
de la copie du virus
des experts de l'industrie peuvent être
déjà dessinés les produits à rencontrer
les exigences élevées du monde de la
santé en europe ya beaucoup de masques a
été fait mais que le gouvernement puisse
dire ben qui peut qui peuvent pas les
acheter parce que il crée plus de
problèmes qu'ils n'en résolvent
veste est pro estime que son modèle de
masques de base protection pourrait être
en production très rapidement pour le
fameux m 95
le défi plus important on parle d'un à
deux mois ce masque la dépendent à mende
avec quelle matière les faits il peut
être de niveau
d'un niveau n 95 par exemple d'un niveau
reconnu ça va vraiment dépendre la
matière la directrice d'investec trop
quoi qu'il faut mieux coordonner les
efforts toutes les initiatives qu'on
voit fleurir aujourd'hui des cohortes de
couture ou des entreprises qui veulent
se lancer dans la fabrication de masques
c'est ce soit c'est bien parce qu'on
voit qu'il ya un bel élan de solidarité
mais en même temps ça répond pas aux
normes de sécurité selon l'industrie
c'est le gouvernement qui doit assurer
le leadership le gouvernement et tout le
système de provisionnement de services
de santé on lui dit on est ouvert on est
prêts on est aux mains des gens au
travail ici normal grondin radio canada
montréal